[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNIFER SU: Hi, folks.
I'm Jennifer Su, the Product
Manager for Job Search
and Cloud Talent Solution.
First, I want to thank everyone
for joining me this morning.
And it looks like we
have a full house.
So it's really inspiring to
see so many people engaged
in diversity and inclusion.
So before we get
started, I want to let
folks know that this
session will be recorded,
and we'll share
it shortly after.
We'll also save some
time for Q&A at the end.
And just a quick reminder,
if you have questions
throughout the session,
just go into the Q&A link.
And there you can
submit your questions,
and we'll try to cover
as many as we can.
But we'll also follow
up after if we can't.
So today, we'll talk about how
the definition of diversity
is evolving along with the
applications of machine
learning when applied in the
talent space can be biased.
Then I'll share how we're
helping businesses transform
recruiting with
Cloud Talent Solution
and how we're helping to
make jobs on career sites
more discoverable and developing
with inclusion as part
of the design.
And finally, I'm excited to
have our customers here with us
today.
SmashFly and Cox Enterprise will
talk about their own diversity
and inclusion efforts and their
experience with Cloud Talent
Solution.
Now let's get started.
Diversity and inclusion is
starting to gain momentum
in the workplace.
78% of professionals
and hiring managers
said that diversity is a top
trend impacting how they hire.
The nudge comes from
leadership where 69% of CEOs
rank diversity and inclusion
as a top business priority.
Leading companies that
are working successfully
towards inclusion
have also achieved
tangible financial benefits
where gender diverse executive
teams are 21% more
likely to experience
above average profitability.
And it's not just gender.
They had similar findings with
ethnic and cultural diversity.
So it's not only the
right thing to do,
but it's also good for business.
While there's
still a lot of work
to be done in terms of
demographic representation,
the definition of diversity
is evolving, expanding
beyond the traditional
gender or ethnicity
to include the many other
dimensions that make us
who we are, such as
our age, whether or not
we are a caretaker,
or perhaps a veteran.
And blend this with
cognitive diversity,
which includes our personalities
and our thinking styles.
This is because the
two work in tandem.
Cognitive diversity brings
the mental frameworks
that people use to
help solve problems.
And demographic diversity
taps into that knowledge
and elicit cognitive diversity
through its indirect effect
on personal behavior.
Think about the last time
you had a great brainstorming
session with your team and
how different everyone was.
As a product manager,
my favorite moments
were seeing the conversations
between our ontologist, who
studied gene therapy,
and a lead engineer, who
worked on quantum computing,
or our marketing lead who
researched education with a
designer who was previously
an optometrist.
My team is also made up
of veterans, Millennials,
to Gen X and Z, and caretakers.
New ideas come from a
diverse way of thinking.
When high performing teams
are both demographically
and cognitively diverse,
there's a 20% increase
in creativity and innovation.
I'm sure you all
have heard a lot
about the digital transformation
these past few days.
The key to the
digital transformation
starts with a workforce and
having the right talent.
AI can help transform
businesses through recruiting
to help discover new jobs and
a more representative candidate
pipeline.
But the recruiting space is
riddled with complex and messy
data.
Take, for example, nurses.
There are hundreds of different
nurse titles and hundreds
of different certifications.
And that's because nurses
also have specialties
within departments, such as
the ICU that contains surgical,
pediatric, or neurotrauma
nurses, just to name a few.
So when job descriptions
are vague, such as "nurse,"
and doesn't include the
department, or cases
when it says "or
equivalent experience,"
the process is time-consuming
and frustrating.
Similar to how you can find
a lot of software engineering
jobs, but the details matter
between mobile iOS and Android
or programming languages
such as Java or Python.
For years, employers
have used systems
to help fill job openings, but
the methods were often crude.
A computer would identify
keywords on job descriptions,
then determine whether or
not those exact keywords are
present on a resume.
Here are some of the challenges
in developing a model
in recruiting for a nurse.
On the resume is a job
title for an OB GYN.
And on the job posting,
it's an LDRP nurse.
There wasn't a match because
the keywords were not exactly
the same, even though
they're synonymous.
This is because
at some hospitals,
an LDRP nurse stands for
labor, delivery, recovery,
and postpartum nurse, which
is similar to an OB GYN nurse.
Next, it's difficult
to track all
the possible accredited
colleges, the various spellings
and abbreviations, and what
counts as "or equivalent."
And the same can be
applied for licenses.
Lastly, the job posting requires
an advanced cardiovascular life
support certification.
There was no match because
it's not listed on the resume.
But most nurses
and recruiters know
that employers provide this
training for free if you don't
have it or need a refresher.
And these are just
a few examples where
there's room for improvement.
As you're all aware, it's
important to think about bias
when using machine
learning in hiring.
The common issues
stem from four areas.
Unclear use cases,
where there's too much
focus on the solution
instead of the problem.
So before digging into
the various models,
take a human-centered approach,
and establish a clear use case
first.
Misaligned expectations,
where there's a tendency
to just throw everything
at a model and just
let it figure it out.
Small data sets, where there
isn't enough training data
to learn all the
various patterns.
So make sure you have
a lot of relevant data.
And biased data.
So spend time examining
the training data for bias.
For the leaders in
our audience, these
are important
considerations when
deciding on developing
in-house or evaluating
technology providers.
Now let's go
through how to apply
these methods in recruiting.
Here's an example of a
nurse job search query.
Based on the data,
there's a need
for identifying 12-hour shifts
and narrowing location radius
to five miles.
But we only know half the story
of what they're looking for
and not why.
After speaking to
users, we learned
that the assumptions based on
just the data were misleading.
When nurses look for jobs,
it's in terms of shifts
where longer shifts
also implies fewer days.
This nurse was actually looking
for a part time job that's
only two days a week and not a
60-hour per week job that pays
overtime, and a need
to commute by bike
and not necessarily
within five miles.
By taking a human-centered
approach and speaking to users,
we can understand why and
develop the right solutions
that addresses their needs.
And then we can
revisit and understand
if we're looking
at the right data.
Now let's look at something
more complex where the use
case is screening a resume.
Here the job description
asks for an RN
with a bachelor's
degree in nursing,
and provides emotional
care to patients.
We reason that education
information would satisfy
the education requirement.
As for emotional care,
it requires the ability
to empathize and communicate.
Volunteer work is probably
a strong signal for empathy.
As for good
communication skills,
recent studies show that
multilingual people have
better communication skills.
And you probably didn't need
to know that they're female.
So our hypothesis is,
volunteer work and languages
are features that can
predict the ability
to provide emotional care.
And by developing
a hypothesis, it
helps identify
reasonable features
to begin with and
iterate on along
with the ability to detect if
the necessary data is missing.
Not to mention, it also
aims towards a less complex
solution, and this makes it
easier to debug and improve
on the model.
Machine learning models
require a lot of relevant data.
How much is a lot?
That depends on the problem.
But the more data typically
improves your model.
A good rule of thumb is
to have at least thousands
of examples for a basic linear
model and hundreds of thousands
for a neural network.
For example, in terms
of nursing jobs,
we'll need at least
thousands of labeled examples
for both the positive
and negative cases.
So this means
thousands of nurses
that can provide emotional
care and thousands that
can't, and across all of the
different types of nurses.
So if there are 10
different types,
then we're looking at
least 20,000 examples
for a basic linear model.
And if a neural
network is needed,
then the order of magnitude
is in the millions.
So if you have
less data, consider
finding a partner that can
bring the necessary data
scale needed.
Now, before we go into
examining the data,
if everyone in the audience
can imagine a shoe.
Now raise your hand if
you imagine sneakers.
High heels?
High tops?
Anyone, high tops?
No.
Given that majority raise
their hands to sneakers,
we've immediately
introduced a bias.
And to add more complexity,
what color were they?
Here are four types of bias.
Something that impacts all data
collected is reporting bias.
Reporting bias occurs when
people annotate the frequency
of things that doesn't
reflect the real world
frequency but things
that they found
interesting or worth noting.
So for this example,
for sneakers,
you may not know that sneakers
have rubber soles when relying
on the top text frequency.
And this is because
rubber soles is ordinary
and can go without saying.
Sampling bias where the data
source is not representative
of all the different variants.
For our shoes, we only had
those that were typical to us.
But we were missing Oxford's,
sandals, or rain boots.
Latent bias when the model is
only shown a specific example.
So if the historical data
only contains sneakers,
then it would be
biased towards sneakers
and would not label
high heels correctly.
And interaction bias that
occurs by the way in which users
interact with it.
So in this room, if everyone
kept selecting sneakers
in a game, then the model
will learn from the activity
and be biased towards sneakers.
And these are just a few
out of more than 100 types
of different human
biases that may occur
in machine learning data sets.
So make sure to
examine your data
and audit it for any
human biases that may
skew your model's predictions.
By using a
human-centered approach,
you can establish
a clear use case
by speaking to users
to focus on the problem
and then to develop a hypothesis
to determine what features
and data are necessary.
And make sure you
have a lot of data.
In recruiting, it's hard to have
a lot of label data in hiring
data, which is especially
difficult across every single
occupation.
Lastly, examine the data.
Machine learning models
will reflect the data
that they're trained on.
So analyze your data carefully
to ensure you understand it.
And for our leaders
in the audience,
a lot of relevant
data is necessary.
So if you don't
have enough data,
consider finding a provider that
can bring the necessary data
scale and develop AI with care.
Our team is using AI
to enhance and expand
what's possible in
recruiting, which
is a critical function of each
and every growing business.
Now I'll go over what we've
built in Cloud Talent Solution
to transform the job
search experience.
In job search,
sometimes the results
don't match the
job seekers intent.
In turn, that misunderstanding
causes hours of work
to find the right job
while others give up
and look somewhere else.
This is a huge
inefficiency that I'm
sure frustrates not just the
job seeker but businesses
as well, because businesses
spend a lot of effort
to get traffic on their sites
but may lose the candidates
before they even see the job.
Here's an example
of a job search
for nurse assistant, which is
someone who supports and helps
nurses.
There are 114 results.
But it turns out,
many of these jobs
are not even for the right role.
The top result, the top
four results actually,
are for nurses and
not the assistant.
The first job is an
administrative nurse.
The second is a senior
nurse that's an instructor.
And the fourth result
is a nurse practitioner
that requires a master's
degree in nursing.
To help solve these problems,
we developed Cloud Talent
Solution.
Cloud Talent Solution
is a set of APIs
and using machine learning
to better understand job
content and job seeker intent.
Candidates get matched to
their ideal jobs faster,
and employers attract and
convert higher quality
candidates by showing
more relevant results.
At the core is a neural network
to understand jobs, companies,
skills, and education.
You can think of it as a
two-sided matching engine that
takes in the job seekers intent
and employer job openings
and runs them through a set
of algorithms to determine
if there's a match or not.
It's all about understanding
the semantics around people
and the semantics
around jobs and using
the power of machine learning to
make the best matches possible.
Here's an example of how Cloud
Talent Solution understands
a job seekers query.
Let's start unpacking this.
Part time CNA WA Australia.
Part time is an employment type.
CNA is an acronym for the
job title certified nursing
assistant.
This means a person is looking
for all job content related
to the occupation that includes
nurse aide and patient care
assistant.
WA Australia is a region and
acronym for Western Australia.
This includes much
of the Outback
but also contains
Perth and all the way
to Broome, a port
city in the North.
All these signals are
important to consider
when capturing a job seeker's
query to understand the intent
and return all relevant jobs.
Underneath the hood of
many of the features
and functionalities of
Cloud Talent Solutions
sits machine learning.
We developed the
models specifically
for the recruiting domain from
heuristic to neural networks
that helps classify jobs so that
businesses can leverage facets
in their UI, or semantics to
match the different languages
that employers and job seekers
speak, such as the LDRP
and the OB-GYN nurse.
Here, using TensorFlow,
we're able to visualize
text embeddings of job titles.
Text embeddings are
co-occurrences of terms
represented in a vector.
Words and phrases that
appear similar in context
within employment-related
data are
trained to be close in
the embedding space.
The resulting dense
representation
allow us to train deep
neural networks that
takes jobs as input.
For example, in the
visual is a cluster
of nurses where the
different nurse terms are
close in proximity,
such as the LPN, which
stands for a licensed practical
nurse, and the school nurse.
And terms that are further away,
such as the medical technician,
are less similar.
My team is actively working
to improve inclusion
by taking a human-centered
approach by using design
and AI to reduce repetitive
tasks and free people
to focus on what humans do best.
They build relationships
and solve problems.
For job search, this means
we engage a diverse set
of job seekers across
different dimensions,
such as occupations,
gender, or career stages
from entry level to
those nearing retirement.
This helps us understand the
different use case scenarios
and build a rich variety
of user perspectives.
We're also working on improving
inclusion in our model training
procedures, such as
detecting and measuring bias
and diversifying our data.
Ultimately, we think AI will
have the greatest impact when
everyone can access it and
when it's built with everyone's
benefit in mind.
Over the past few
years, our team
has spent time with
hundreds of people
to understand their
job search journey
I met a woman who was blind.
And as we were searching for
jobs across various sites,
we came across a company
that she was interested in.
But we realized that the job
detail page was not accessible,
even though the rest
of the site was.
While I could read the
job description to her,
she told me not to
bother because the career
site is her first impression
of a career at that company.
And if that is
inaccessible, then
what would it be like on a
daily basis working there?
Job search is one of the first
impressions a candidate has
with a business.
So it's important to make
jobs on your career site
more discoverable to a
larger group of candidates
and make the experience
more inclusive.
Now I'll go over a
few features we've
developed to help
businesses reach
more demographically and
cognitively diverse candidates.
Each year, over a quarter
of a million service members
transition from the US
military to the civilian world.
We've spoken to many
service members.
And it turns out
the language used
to describe the military
service and civilian employment
is not always similar.
Many transitioning
service members
need a way to translate their
experience so that they don't
miss out on great opportunities,
and businesses don't miss out
on great candidates.
We also learned that
in the US military,
occupational codes are used
to identify specific jobs.
To assist service
members transitioning
to the civilian world,
we've added military codes
to our understanding
of occupations
to surface the
relevant civilian jobs.
We're thrilled to have
RecruitMilitary in the audience
today.
Hey, Mike.
They are a veteran
recruiting company in the US
that represents over
a million veterans.
Since implementing Cloud Talent
Solution on their job board,
they've seen record
highs of almost twice
as many applications.
And we're proud to help
them with their mission
to connect more
transitioning veterans
to their first civilian job.
Another example is our global
language support in our service
that leverages the
tight integration
with Google Translate
Neural Machine Translations.
Back in the old days,
traditional phrase-based
translation systems
performed their tasks
by breaking up sentences
into multiple chunks
and then translate
them, phrase by phrase.
This led to a disfluency
in the translation outputs
and was not quite like
how we humans translate.
We read the whole sentence,
understand its meaning,
and then translate it.
Neural Machine
Translation mimics that.
Here's an example.
[SPEAKING SPANISH] Neural
Machine Translations
considers the entire
input sentence
as a unit of translation.
So instead of assistant
nursing certified,
we're able to translate and
return certified nursing
assistant jobs.
We also learned that across the
US in major metropolitan areas,
over 100 different languages
are spoken at home.
And in Europe, a large
portion of Europeans
frequently search online
in their first language.
A few weeks ago, we announced
an exciting new feature.
For those who prefer to search
in their first language,
we also return the
relevant jobs that
were posted in English so
that these job seekers don't
miss out on jobs that they
would have otherwise missed.
And finally, commuting is
one of the top considerations
for a job, where 85%
of US professionals
would take a pay cut
for a shorter commute.
Our commute search
feature surfaces jobs
based on commute time
and transportation modes.
As you can imagine, to determine
the shortest commute time,
you'll have to identify all
the relevant different route
options between two
points to answer queries.
These permutations become costly
as the scale of the problem
increases from one metropolitan
area to an entire country
or continent where
10,000 stops already
yields 100 million pairs.
We leveraged a tight
integration with Google Maps
to gather this
information layering
in our knowledge of jobs where
we've mapped millions of jobs
and developed the technology
to answer all of these commute
time queries on the fly.
As part of our
research in speaking
to a broad base of
users, we learned
that some people need
alternative commute methods,
especially those living
in low income communities
or the nurse that was searching
for a job within biking
distance.
Recently, we announced
new commute methods
so that everyone can
find work no matter
how they choose to get there.
Overall, our clients
are seeing great results
that include reduced
development time that saves them
at least an entire sprint
each year on their roadmap
and double digit gains in
their key performance metrics,
such as applications, and an
increase in higher quality
candidates.
Now let's hear directly from
customers about their diversity
goals, experience with their
recent integration with Cloud
Talent Solution, and how they're
leveraging inclusive features.
Today we have Thom Kenney,
the CEO of SmashFly.
And Thom brings over 20 years
of leadership experience
in high growth companies.
We also have Adam Glassman,
the Senior Manager
of Employment Branding
at Cox Enterprise,
and has experience in
marketing, branding, and talent
acquisition.
Please welcome them
onto the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks for joining us today.
We're really excited about
SmashFly's recent integration
with Cloud Talent
Solution and how
we've been able to showcase
some of our inclusive features
on Cox Enterprises career site.
Adam, can you tell us a
bit about yourself and Cox
Enterprise and share
your perspective
on the candidate experience?
ADAM GLASSMAN: Sure, absolutely.
Good morning, everybody.
My name is Adam Glassman.
And as Jen mentioned, I
lead the Employment Brand
and Recruitment Marketing
Team at Cox Enterprises.
So who is Cox Enterprises?
Well, we are one of the top
privately held companies
in the country, but also
one of the country's best
kept secrets.
We're a $20 billion organization
whose three primary business
divisions include Cox
Communications, Cox Automotive,
and Cox Media Group.
And under those
divisions, there are
brands that you know, like
Autotrader, "Kelley Blue
Book," and Blueprint RF.
Our technology
and software teams
are really at the
forefront of disrupting
a majority of these industries,
and it's really a great time
to be part of the team
simply because of that.
Across the globe, we're
60,000 employees strong,
all focused on
one primary thing,
and that's to build a better
future for the next generation.
And we do that through a
number of different ways,
both for our employees, our
communities, our industries,
and our planet.
To your second question, Jen,
about the candidate experience,
it may actually come as a
shock to those in the room,
but most people find searching
for a job somewhat frustrating.
And it can be a very
difficult process,
and they don't have recruiters
hounding them and stalking them
online, like I'm
sure most of you do.
For most members who are
looking for a new job,
the onus is really on them
to look for a new company,
to find a match both from a
culture perspective, a location
perspective, and a
brand perspective,
and to find that right
opportunity at the right time.
And so they take a lot
of time researching.
And there are a number
of different sites
that they visit to do that,
including a company career
site.
And so as they go
through their research
phase and their
process, that experience
can somewhat feel
a little clunky
to them, especially at the point
where they're ready to apply.
Most companies ask individuals
to apply online today.
And many of them don't
even allow that application
to be mobile-friendly.
So there is another point of
contention for candidates.
If you are actually
applying on a desktop,
the application can
still feel very clunky.
It feels outdated.
It's long and laborious, and so
there is continued frustration
through that process.
Once you actually
apply, you tend to wait,
and you wait some more.
And ultimately,
if your background
meets what the company
is looking for,
you hear back from a recruiter.
And that starts
you down the path
of potentially several
rounds of interviews,
which again can feel a
little laborious depending
on the company.
I will say, across
our industry, there
is a renewed sense of focus
on creating a better candidate
experience.
And so that gives
me some optimism
for the future of how we
can improve that experience.
And I think
technology and AI can
be avenues for us to do that.
JENNIFER SU: Thanks, Adam.
It's great to be
partnering with you
and to help improve the
candidate experience.
Thom, could you share
a bit about SmashFly
and how AI can help transform
recruiting for your enterprise
clients?
THOM KENNEY: Sure.
Thanks for having
me this morning.
I apologize for the glare a
little bit for those of you
who are seeing
the bright lights.
It is actual baldness.
It's not fake.
SmashFly is a company that was
founded about 12 years ago.
And it was founded
with a purpose,
to really connect the right
talent, with the right hiring
managers, at the right time.
It's a very simple prospect.
But when you think about the
complexity of how people look
for jobs, how jobs are
posted, where jobs are posted,
and with what Jen was showing
earlier, all the different ways
that employers are using
language, and using colors
and styles to try
to attract talent,
there's no one single best way.
And when SmashFly really
started to take a look at this
and the technology
a few years ago,
we recognized there was
a huge opportunity for us
to leverage some of the
AI and ML techniques
to learn how talent is
engaging with employers
but then also how employers
are engaging with talent.
So when we think
about it, SmashFly
is in 69 countries
around the world
where we have
recruiters working.
And we have talent that
interface with us in over 180
countries around the world.
And if you think about the
micro-climates of recruiting
that that represents, it's
almost infinite in the number
of complications
with the way people
would interface together,
the employers and the talent.
So when we think about
especially the machine learning
aspects, there's tons
of data available.
And you ask any data scientist
or machine learning person,
and they're going to tell you
the two most important things
that they need are data--
lots of it-- but
data that's good.
Jen talked about the
training data sets.
And we looked at the training
data sets that we would have
and the value that it brought.
So we're leveraging the
AI and ML techniques
to really use that amount
of volumous information
that we have--
1.2 million hires that we've
done through the SmashFly
platform--
and really move those forward
in a way that engages talent,
engages them in a way that gets
them excited about an employer.
It's not just about Cox.
You don't just know
Cox Communication
as your cable company.
I was talking to Adam
earlier, and he's
got this whole
automotive division,
which was really crazy.
And then print and web
media, radio media.
It's a huge conglomerate
organization.
Well, how does SmashFly
help Cox with that?
It's like, we really try to
move that emotive action.
How do you create that
connection with the employer?
And there's no way to do
this in a human function.
We could have hundreds of people
looking at these job postings,
looking at the way people are
tracking, looking at reports.
But they're not going to be
doing a good enough job for us,
because we need to
be moving faster.
We need to be looking
in places that we never
thought to look before.
So the AI and ML
construct's really
what's going to
move that forward.
And if you think about
it, one of the things
that we're really trying
to do, because it's
that emotive response
that we want,
we're not trying to
eliminate the human.
We actually have a
customer of ours.
Global company, great company,
very recognizable brand name.
They took a year to
build a system that
would use machine learning,
deep learning, neural networks.
And they were going
to create a process
by which they were going to
find the best candidates that
existed out there.
And they put this
system in place.
They spent millions of
dollars building it.
And six months after
they put it in place,
they realized 50% fewer people
were accepting their job
offers.
And the reason was they'd
eliminated the human element
completely.
So when we think
about it at SmashFly,
all the great technology
that's out there,
it's not about replacing
the human element.
It's about augmenting
what humans naturally do,
what they do best.
So help the talent
find the human that's
trying to hire them and get
to those outcomes much faster.
JENNIFER SU: Thanks, Thom.
We're excited to bring AI with
the human-centered approach
to your clients' talent
acquisition process.
Now I'd love to hear from
you both about the importance
of responsible AI and
inclusive hiring practices.
Thom, would you like
to start with why
this is important to SmashFly
and to your customers?
THOM KENNEY: Everything
about bias in human resources
and in recruiting is one of the
biggest topics we have today.
How do you create that
inclusive environment?
How do you create diversity?
And if anybody watched
the news this morning,
Gizmodo posted
something that Congress
has introduced a bill
that will require
companies that do AI to document
how it is eliminating bias.
I mean, that's a
pretty big step,
because now we're
recognizing the power of AI
and the power of
machine learning.
And now you've got
people worried about it
and starting to regulate it.
Whether that's good
or bad is indifferent.
But it really raises
the level of awareness
about how diversity, inclusion,
and bias works in systems.
There's a great
company out there,
Intel, where their CEO
a few years ago said,
we want to create a diverse
workforce that exceeds
the standards across the board.
If the standard in our industry
is 30% women engineers,
we want to do that.
If the standard
across the industry
is 50% African-American,
we want to do that.
So not creating some
pie in the sky numbers,
but creating something that
says the industry standards are
this, and we're not there.
And the "Forbes" articles
that you read about this
are just fascinating.
The CEO created a Big,
Hairy, Audacious Goal.
Anybody's read
Kotter from Harvard
knows the BHAG is a way to
really inspire people and get
them to move to a goal.
And they set the goal for
2020, but they achieved it long
before that.
And so when we think
about it, working with Cox
and working with other
customers that we have,
they want the diverse
and inclusive workforces.
They bring different skill sets.
I don't know how
many of you would
think that my first career
was as an opera singer.
I had a great time.
I sang in seven different
languages, sang in Europe,
sang in the US, had
a really great time.
I had a tumor in my throat.
Ended my opera career.
Technology was a cool thing
at the time in the '90s.
So I thought, what the heck?
I'll do that.
But it's one of
those things where
I think about
things a little bit
differently than maybe a
classically trained engineer
would.
And that just little
bit of diversity with me
adds some color to
the employee base.
And when we leverage tools,
especially the Google search
that we put in
place for Cox, we're
leveraging a way
that we're trying
to create that diverse and that
inclusive environment in ways
that we don't want
the humans just
to make that judgment call.
Because even if you make a
judgment call about diversity,
you're still using
your inherent bias
to make that judgment call.
So let's build systems and
processes that actually empower
the human engagement
in a way that we
develop these inclusive
relationships with people.
A diverse workforce,
an inclusive workforce
is one that actually
transforms industries.
We see this research everywhere.
And our ability to provide
that to our customers
is one of the most
important things
that we can do at SmashFly.
JENNIFER SU: Great.
Thank you, Thom.
We're excited and share
this vision with you.
Adam, if you can speak more
on this topic as an enterprise
customer of the technology,
what does inclusive hiring
mean to Cox as a hiring
company and as a business?
ADAM GLASSMAN: Sure.
So the important thing
to understand about Cox
is that diversity and
inclusion are not buzzwords.
It's not PR.
It's not publicity.
It really is a core foundational
value within the company.
And it's been held since its
very inception 120 years ago.
And because it is a core
foundational value for us,
we act with intention to try to
make the workplace as inclusive
as possible.
And that takes several
different phases.
If you think about the
journey that somebody
would take at the very
early point of connecting
with a brand and
applying for a position,
it's that career site
experience as well that Jen
had talked about
with accessibility
and making sure that
their search is connecting
in the way that
is good for them.
It's the language we use
on our job descriptions.
It's the way a recruiter
evaluates talent and recommends
them to a hiring manager.
It's the way a hiring
manager evaluates talent
to ultimately make the offer
for someone to join the company.
It's the way an employee
experiences their work
within the company.
And so at Cox, we have steps
along these different journey
paths to make sure that
we are providing the most
inclusive area as possible.
We know that as a
business, we want
to have those diverse ideas,
and those diverse perspectives,
and those backgrounds.
Number one, it's the
right thing to do.
But number two, it does
make our business stronger.
From a cultural perspective,
that is something
that we act with intention on.
And then, we know
that employees, when
they feel warm and welcomed
in an organization,
and they can feel comfortable
in their own skin,
they perform at a high level.
And they can do amazing things.
At Cox, we do have
gender diversity
at the executive level.
Which I'm proud to say,
of our four divisions,
we have Chief Human Resource
officers at each of them,
and all four of them are female.
Across the board,
we've been recognized
by a number of different
diversity organizations
for our efforts,
including the Human Rights
Campaign, "Forbes,"
DiversityInc, among others.
JENNIFER SU: Great.
Thank you, Adam.
It's really inspiring to hear
about Cox's diversity inclusion
values.
Now I'd like to hear from you
both about why you were excited
about our recent integration
and the inclusive features,
such as the veterans job search,
the multilingual support,
and commute search.
Thom, would you like to start?
THOM KENNEY: So one of
the biggest things for us
when we were looking at
the Google search was,
what do we buy, and
what do we build?
And when we looked at
our implementation,
it was obvious to us that when
you talk about natural language
processing, you talk
about semantic analysis,
you talk about just
search in general,
Google's the world
leader in that space.
So when we thought about, how
do we develop a better search
capability for these jobs, it
was a clear cut answer for us
to partner with Google on this.
And when you look at
our base of customers,
like I mentioned
earlier, 69 countries
we have recruiters working in.
The ability to leverage the
multi-language capabilities
is huge for us, and it's
huge for our customers.
To be able to say
very, very simply,
I need to find a job
with the language
that I'm most
comfortable in, maybe
with a second language
shown to me that I'm also
comfortable in, in
multilingual societies,
and be able to create that
connection very, very quickly.
And when you think
about it, even
from the most simplest
things, the user experience,
today with most search
systems, you can say,
I want to find an
engineering job.
Well, if you put in
"software engineer,"
and it's a basic Boolean
and/or construct,
you're going to end up with job
postings with product people,
and marketing people, and
salespeople because they're all
going to say, has to
work well with engineers
if you're a technology company.
So you're going to get
all these jobs come up
because it's not smart enough
to really understand it.
And if you do it
just by job title,
then if you put
engineer in that search,
you're going to miss
all the jobs that are
listed as software developer.
So it's not really
going to help you.
One of the things that we saw
with Google was the ability
to say, well, I'm looking
for an engineer position.
And you type it in with
E-N-G-I-N-E-R. You misspell it.
Well guess what?
You still get the relevant
engineer positions
that still come up.
But one of the bigger
things that we saw,
it's near and dear to my heart,
the military occupational
specialty codes and the
ability to search for that.
And I've been a part time
military guy for 23 years now.
I'm still an executive officer
of an airborne battalion
in New Jersey.
And I know how hard
it is, not just
for people that are
transitioning from active duty,
but people who are reservists
who have spent years trying
to build up some skills
in the Army Reserve
that they don't know
how to translate
into the civilian world.
And a lot of these
guys struggle.
Especially since 2003, I
was deployed for about 4
and 1/2 years up to about 2014.
And those are tough deployments,
and those are tough things
to come home to.
And you don't always know
how to make that transition.
Even if you're a
part time person,
and you go away for 15
months and you come back,
your job's gone, or
your wife's gone,
or there's a challenge
in your life.
And you've got to find
that next opportunity.
Well, helping people translate
that into a real valuable job
prospectus is hugely important
for the veterans community.
And it was interesting.
Last night, we were
walking back from dinner.
And I was walking down the
streets of San Francisco.
And I was thinking about
this inclusion and diversity,
and what am I going
to talk about?
And it was
interesting, because I
noticed as I walked,
probably 10%,
15% of the folks that I saw
on the side of the street,
they're wearing a jacket from
the Gulf War in the '90s.
They're wearing a jacket
from the early days
of the wars in Iraq or
Afghanistan or a recent jacket.
Because if you're
a military person,
you actually know the different
uniforms that have been issued.
And you know by the
uniform what time period
that uniform was designed for.
And I had to think to myself,
we've done 1.2 million jobs
for people around the world.
How many of those people that
are on the street are veterans?
And how many of those people,
if we knew how to reach them,
and we could give
them the capability
to find that right next
opportunity, how many of them
would still be on the street?
And how many of them could we
help lead really productive
lives and be a part
of our society?
Because that's what diversity
and inclusion is all about.
It's about finding the
right opportunities
for the right people
and the right companies
and giving them something to be
proud about every single day.
ADAM GLASSMAN: Yeah, I agree
with everything that you said,
Thom.
Two additional features that I
know I've been impressed with
are that commute search and the
multi-language capabilities.
So if you start with
the commute search,
one of my jobs in
employment brand
is to tell a very real,
authentic story of who
we are as a company and
match that with what
the candidate is looking for.
So we're not trying to oversell.
We're trying to actually
tell a real story so
that the candidate
is more informed,
and they ultimately
accept a job at a company
that they're looking for.
From a commute perspective,
look, let's be honest.
In the majority of our
cities, traffic stinks.
And so, who wants to sit for
two hours in rush hour traffic
going back and forth to a job?
Most people are looking for
a very specific commute time.
And we can't always change
where our office locations are,
and we don't always have
remote work and work
from home opportunities.
So that commute search is
a very important factor
in what people are looking
for in a career and in a job.
Because the worst
scenario for us
is that somebody would
ultimately accept the job,
and they were really looking
for a 15-minute commute,
but it turns out it's two hours.
And two months down the
road, they're miserable
and they quit.
And that doesn't help anybody.
You have to start the process
all over again on both sides.
So that's the worst
case scenario for us.
And I think that
commute search is
another one of
those features that
help improve the experience
and bring that information
right into the
candidate's fingertips.
The second piece is the
multi-language capabilities.
And so Jen talked a little
bit about that earlier,
but if we looked at five random
companies in the country,
and they had the
same five positions,
I bet you dollars to
donuts that they'd all
title them differently.
So five companies with
the same five jobs,
they'd all have
different titles on them.
And so that's in
the same language.
Now imagine if you don't
speak that language natively.
We know that translating
isn't always one to one.
The grammar is different.
The syntax is different.
And so if you're trying to
search in your native language,
which isn't necessarily
the native language
that the company has
posted in, good luck
trying to find that job match.
And so this is another
one of those features that
puts the information at
the candidate's fingertips
to help improve the experience.
So I'm excited
about both of those.
JENNIFER SU: Adam, Thom, thank
you both for joining us today.
We're excited to be
working alongside with you
to connect more
candidates with jobs.
Please give them around of
applause, to Adam and Thom.
ADAM GLASSMAN: Thank you.
JENNIFER SU: So
you've heard how AI
can help with inclusive hiring
and how critical it is to get
this right for our customers.
Now I'll run through
a few takeaways,
and then we can get
to your questions.
To wrap up, the
definition of diversity
is evolving to be
more inclusive.
And it's not only the
right thing to do,
but it's also good for business.
AI can transform recruiting,
but applying AI to recruiting
has its risk and needs
to be handled with care.
By using a human-centered
approach and speaking to users,
you can establish
a clear use case
and develop a
hypothesis to determine
what features and
data are necessary,
then ensure you have a
lot of relevant data,
and examine that data.
If you're considering
recruitment technology,
ensure your providers can
bring the necessary data scale
and develop AI with care.
Cloud Talent Solution is
transforming recruiting with AI
and inclusive features, .
And we're seeing
positive results.
Lastly, it's
important to remember,
as creators or
influencers of technology,
it's our responsibility
to develop with inclusion
as part of the design.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]